en el segundo día de audiencias en las
afueras del tribunal penal de old bailey
un grupo de manifestantes que simpatiza
con la causa de julian assange se dio
cita desde temprana hora este martes
para apoyar al fundador de wikileaks
pidiendo que se detenga su extradición a
eeuu y que lo liberen cuanto antes entre
otras de las consignas piden que el
periodismo no sea penalizado porque el
periodismo no es un crimen además
mientras el grupo de simpatizantes entre
los que se encuentran varios
latinoamericanos se encuentran afuera de
la corte adentro el fundador de
wikileaks se presenta por segundo día
consecutivo en este proceso de
extradición que se espera dure cuatro
semanas el día de hoy se espera la
comparecencia del
profesor en periodismo de la universidad
de maryland mark feldman quien en el día
de ayer no pudo presentar su
comparecencia vía remota desde eeuu
debido a que hubo problemas técnicos